It's week two, and
it is cake week, and...
Wow! Noel, that is amazing!
I love your commitment
to the theme of the week.
No, I mean... No, no,
don't have to explain.
I've totally got it.
You are Marie Antoinette,
because what is the one thing
that we all know about her?
That she famously said, "Let them
eat cake," and it's Cake Week.
I just... I love that you've bothered.
I mean, I don't want
to nit-pick, you know,
cos historically probably
she never said it.
I think it's one of the
great misquotes of history.
If anything, she would have
said, "Let them eat brioche."
But chances are she
never even mentioned cake.
I mean, people just said it about her
because, you know, they were
mean. But honestly, well done.
I don't know what you're talking about.
These are the only clothes
I had left that were clean.
Clean is good.
Last time...
Come on, biscuits.
...Briony saw herself rising to the top.
I love the balloons. Can
we eat a balloon? Please do.
But it was Manon...
I think you've done an
amazing job. Thank you.
...who was crowned this
year's first Star Baker.
And although Ruby crumbled...
I am losing it, Noel.
...it was Imelda...
Oh, sugar plum fairies!
...who was first to leave the tent.
Now it's Cake Week.
This is not going to go well.
The Signature Bake sees
temperatures rise...
Well, good luck cooling it.
...the bakers go green for
the Technical Challenge...
The weirdest thing
I've ever done for a cake.
...and face a chocolate Showstopper...
Lordy, Lordy. It's hot.
...on one of the hottest days...
...the Bake Off tent has ever seen.
It's OK.
Cake Week. Kind of looking forward to it
cos I've been practising
literally nonstop.
Best of luck.
Even though I'm a baker,
cakes are not really my thing.
So many things that
can go wrong with cake.
Just trying not to
think about that right now.
I am going to run out of time
today so warning, spoiler alert.
Welcome to Cake Week and
your Signature Challenge.
Today, the judges
would like you to create
that classic crowd pleaser, a traybake.
They want you to tray and bake a cake.
That posh accent's not working for you.
You can use any type
of sponge, any flavour,
but you must be able to make 16
identical slices from your traybake.
You've got two hours to complete
your Signature Challenge.
On your marks... get set... bake!
A traybake, as the name
implies, is baked in a tray.
Generally, they're the good,
old reliable sponge cakes
with sort of white icing on top.
But I would like to see
something I've never seen before.
You've got to bite into it.
A little bit of crunch
on the top's nice.
Hit that beautiful sponge
and, of course, flavour -
they must get that flavour
across to us in a very small bite.
Time management is critical.
Get this wrong, they're in
a whole world of trouble.
Good morning, Antony. Hello,
Paul. Morning, Antony. Hello, Prue.
Hey, Noel. Tell us about your traybake.
So it's a frangipane with a
nice sweet pastry, pineapple jam
and then a coconut burfi
on top. What is burfi?
It's like a coconut sweet,
really. Just milk powder,
desiccated coconut... Oh,
delicious... and sugar.
Hi, Mama. How are you? I'm very well.
Antony lives in London
but calls his mum, Maria,
back in Bangalore, every day.
How's the weather in Bangalore?
Oh, it's horrible.
Inspired by the burfi he
ate with his mum as a boy,
Antony's cardamom frangipane traybake
blends Indian sweets with
classic British baking.
Sounds like a slightly different
Bakewell tart, doesn't it?
Yeah, it's like an Indian
Bakewell tart. Yeah.
I think you might have
invented something there. Yeah.
Briony is also attempting
to pull off a culture clash.
I've gone for Spanish flavours
because I'm a massive fan of Spain
and all things Spanish, so I
wanted to sort of incorporate that
into the good old British traybake.
Briony is currently training
for her third half marathon
with her cockapoo, Archie.
And the race is on to
complete her traybake
with an orange pastry base, almond
sponge and a chocolate ganache
on top of a soft Spanish
nougat called a turron.
Hola. Hola. Hola! Hola! Que tal, Sandi?
Do you speak Spanish? Si. Claro que si.
Do, do you really? Yes. I
studied it at university.
And your Danish? No.
Well, I'm going to... I'm up for trying.
We've got time. Yeah, teach me.
You need actually, probably, to get
all the way through to the final,
I'm just saying, if I'm going
to teach you anything. Yeah. OK?
OK, here we go. Jeg Jeg
konge i... konge i...
...Danmark... Danmark.
Og jeg... Og jeg...
...kan lide... kan lide...
...Jordbaer... Jordbaer.
Yeah. What did you just make me say?
"I am the king of Denmark
and I like strawberries."
And I think that is
going to see you though
any part of Denmark
that you wish to go to.
Come on.
Dan is also headed for Europe.
I'm just going to try not to panic,
cos it didn't serve me well last time.
He's off to Germany via the 1970s.
It's a riff on a Black Forest gateau.
Maybe they were trendy
when I was growing up,
but you don't see them much these days.
Despite being too young
to remember the '70s,
as a boy, Black Forest gateau
was Dan's absolute favourite.
He's making a vanilla cream topping
and will decorate with
intricate tempered chocolate,
but he's already discovered a problem.
I thought nobody else would
do it but, unfortunately...
Chocolate, cherries,
cream, is delicious.
...Ruby's stealing my ideas.
Honestly!
Less of that "stealing
the idea" business!
Ruby's ideas in the kitchen
have usually been inspired
by her mum, Kalvinder.
That's good. Got to say,
not as good as Mum's though.
Ruby made her Black Forest gateau
for her family last Christmas.
It has a dark chocolate ganache
and white chocolate drizzle on
top of a moist chocolate sponge.
I'm a bit worried because it's quite
a tender chocolate sponge. Yeah.
How are you going to
get it into neat slices?
The key thing for me is to
make sure that it's chilled,
otherwise it could
turn into a sloppy mess.
Yeah, no pressure.
When it comes to her sponge recipe...
Un, deux, trois, quatre, cinq, six.
...last week's Star Baker, Manon,
has put herself under
even more pressure.
I'm not using any raising action.
I'm only using the egg whites,
actually are going to make it fluffy.
So it's quite a lot of eggs.
When Manon left the family farm in
Brittany for London six years ago,
it awoke a passion for British baking.
Her raising agent-free traybake,
with rosemary, honey and fresh figs,
was one of the first recipes
she learnt in her adoptive home.
My first job in London, there's
a landlady where I used to work -
she made the best honey cake ever.
The risk is that it can not raise.
Terry is taking an even bigger
risk with his sponge batter.
What's this, then?
this is just an apple sauce.
And where's that going? Into my batter.
It's interesting that you're using this
cos there's a lot of liquid in apple.
It's a nice, moist cake
and it's actually it's better
a few days after you make it.
Terry also has the
patience to keep bees.
Looks like I've got a nice
active little queen in there.
Using their honey to
slowly brew his own beer.
Should be a nice, sweet mix.
There's an alcoholic
kick to his traybake,
with rum-soaked raisins and dates
being added to his moist apple sponge.
Are we going to taste the rum? You will.
There is a rum syrup that goes on
the top once the sponge is cool.
A lot of rum? Hopefully.
I'm counting on it.
Some rum shots on the side?
I might. I might, yeah.
Just keep bringing the
rum and Prue will be happy.
Every minute in the
Signature Challenge...
...is now precious.
I need to get this into the oven, ASAP.
The longer the bakers'
large traybake-sized sponges
need in the oven...
Come on.
...the less time they'll have to cool.
And now... waiting time.
And a warm cake can't
be sliced and decorated.
Doesn't that look delicious?
There we go.
That's going to be in
there for about 25 minutes.
This is going in for 35 minutes.
This needs 20 minutes.
It's quite a thin cake.
It's a very short bake time.
So it's got lots of time to cool.
Bake well, my love.
Now there's even more to worry about.
Okey dokey.
The judges will be expecting
each traybake sponge
to be accompanied by complimentary
fillings and toppings.
This is Valencian orange jam but
they still a nice bitter taste.
You know when it's ready
when it hits when it hits 105.
Very helpfully, it says
"jam" on it, actually.
And it also says "hard
crack" on there as well.
I'm not sure what
that temperature's for.
I am making my rosemary
syrup. I love rosemary.
You know, it reminds me of
Welsh lamb like, you know?
While I'm eating a lemon cake.
I think you should wear this one.
Jon also adds an unconventional twist
to his job delivering blood to the NHS
by letting his daughters,
Lucy and Hannah,
choose what he wears to work.
Why not this one? Oh, that is very nice.
Your mother doesn't
like that one at all.
But Mum and the girls have all approved
his Italian meringue-topped traybake
that pairs his favourite herb
with his favourite pudding.
I like lemon meringue pie,
so I thought I would
try a lemon meringue cake
rather than lemon meringue pie.
In the oven, I'm making a
pandan chiffon traybake cake.
And what's pandan?
So pandan is like a long leaf,
and you get the juice from it.
And does the pandan give
colour as well as flavour? Yes.
That's revolting.
Do you know...? Do you
know what it's like?
It's going well, I think.
It's like I just cut me lawn.
It's just like I cut me lawn.
Kim-Joy often bakes treats
for her and her partner Nabil's
marathon board game sessions.
Her pandan and coconut traybake,
topped with palm sugar cream,
is one of his favourites.
It's kind of a love
or hate flavour, so...
Isn't that a dangerous
thing to do? I love it, so...
I quite like it. Do you? It's
like pond water. Yeah, good...
I think that could be delicious. Thanks.
Sort of reminding me of frog spawn.
Lovely.
Bakers, you have one hour left.
Wow, if we've got an hour we could
cut your hair using this bowl.
I'll take that.
There's a saying where I come from
- a watched pot never boils.
The bakers now face a crucial decision.
I'm a bit scared to look in the oven.
Cake's coming out in about a minute.
Take a traybake out of the oven too soon
and the under-baked sponge
could collapse when it's cut.
Leave it too long,
and not only do they risk
running out of cooling time...
Oh, no. Definitely more time.
Yeah, that's done.
...but also tough, crumbly slices.
Let's just wait for it.
Omm.
Might have to whack the oven
temperature up a little bit, maybe.
In fact, I'm going to do that now.
Got about another 15,
20 minutes left yet.
Just a bit of a waiting game now.
Back home in Sheffield, a
bake in the oven means a chance
for Luke to take Ruby, Oscar and Daisy
for one of their two walks a
day with his fiancee, Kelly.
You all right? Yeah,
I'm losing my jeans.
They often return to his classic
lemon and poppy seed traybake,
with a white chocolate
and mascarpone topping.
Not sure if it's cooked
in this little bit.
Yeah, there's this one
little section within it
that just doesn't want to bake.
Whilst most bakers have enough
to worry about with one sponge...
All right.
...one has managed to make his
Signature Challenge twice as hard.
I don't really want to over-bake them.
I don't want to under-bake them either.
Rahul's planned a traybake
that's double layered.
I did quite a lot of
experiment with this recipe.
I baked it, like, five or
six different versions of it.
Rahul often gets his best baking ideas
whilst working out at his local
leisure centre in Rotherham.
It's inspired a seventh version
of his double lemon
joconde sponge traybake,
with Italian meringue buttercream
and now a drizzle with the juice
of four lemons and 25 cardamom pods.
It just smell like, disinfectant
so don't worry about that.
Wow! That's... strong.
Oh, my God. So it does
smell like disinfectant?
Well, I think I certainly wouldn't mind
cleaning the corners of my
fridge with it. Oh, wow, great.
No, I'm sure it will taste delicious.
Right. I'm going to go for it.
I think I'm going to take it out.
♪ Hallelujah! ♪
He is ginormous.
How thick is it? Mine's probably
going to be about that thick.
Oh, no, mine's like that.
Oh, mine's quite deep.
Well, good luck cooling it. Oh, God!
With time running out...
Come on.
...the moment their
sponges are cool enough...
He's big.
...the bakers need to be ready
with all their fillings,
toppings and decorations.
Hopefully I'll squeeze
it in, in ten minutes.
Yeah, you know you're not
actually wearing a watch, right?
Just... that's
not really helping you.
Rum sauce. A tablespoon of rum
in. Just a little extra for Prue.
Hopefully she'll get the
rum flavour from that.
Mixing together the honey and the
sugar and water for the turron.
My marmalade is simmering.
Ganache ganaching.
Maybe I've just done too many things.
At the moment, I'm just piping
some chocolate shapes onto acetate,
and they will stand
upright on top of the cake.
I tried various things for
the topping, unsuccessfully,
and I wanted to use the marzipan and
I just got a flash of inspiration.
Just thought, "Edible
food paint. Metallic."
So it's beautiful and shiny.
Since recently becoming a
grandmother for the first time,
Karen has been devoting
her creative energies
into artistic bakes for her family.
Now then, this seal, do they have legs?
No, they have flippers.
Her striped marzipan will
sit on an almond sponge
layered with a tart rhubarb jam.
I've done the stripy bits, although
I could titivate for a while,
but I'm just putting some
beautiful glitter on it.
Why wouldn't you?
Full disco.
Sandi, we need to do a time call.
Yeah, no, I'm skipping this one.
Bakers, you only have
15 minutes remaining.
So that's a slight worry.
I shall have to caramelise
my nuts a bit quicker.
Now it's messy.
Turron can set quite quickly,
so I have to make that
kind of at the last minute.
It's going to be a rush at the end!
Pushing it a little bit.
Just putting my drizzle into my cake.
I'm just spreading my
Italian meringue buttercream.
I'm reasonably happy.
I think Ruby's struggling
with cooling it down.
It's still way too hot.
Quite warm now, isn't it?
It is very warm.
cheers for that, Sandi.
Is that better? That's amazing.
Right, here we go. Turron on.
It's so sticky.
Mine's roasting.
This bad boy just needs to go
and chill in the fridge, though.
It's too hot. It's going to melt.
This is going to look a mess.
God, I've got to get 16 pieces off this.
The judges have demanded
identical crisp, clean slices.
This is all about precision.
Hopefully get it
looking relatively even.
So I've divided in four,
and each four is going to
be divided into four more.
Un, deux, trois, quatre...
Sorry. So I need to do seize.
Oh, God. They're looking hot.
Some are a bit bigger than others. Oops.
They look so messy and rubbish.
They might not be as finished
as I'd like them to be
but they'll be there.
It's hotting up.
So now the ganache is melting.
I'd like to take a bit
more care in doing this
but I just haven't
got time at the moment.
Bakers, you have one minute remaining.
Oops.
Oh, you mucky pup.
Finished.
What a mess.
Bakers, your time is up.
You're done. Done.
You're done. We're done.
Look at everyone's.
It's just pretty and pretty and
pretty. Pretty, pretty, pretty.
Oh, dear.
It's judgment time for the
bakers' Signature traybakes.
Hello, Rahul. Hi.
They are quite elegant
and it reminds me of an
afternoon tea in a five-star hotel
cos they look like they're finger
sandwiches. Let's have a taste.
You certainly get the
lemon and the cardamom,
and they're in the right
proportion. I think that's very good.
For something that looks like
a wholemeal finger sandwich,
they taste beautiful. Sigh
of relief. Yeah. Thank you.
Cheers. Thanks.
It's quite a tough sponge. And
it's a bit bland as well. OK.
You really have got the balance
of the coconut and the frangipane
absolutely perfect. It's
very delicate. Not as powerful
as I thought it'd be. It is a
little bit of a mess... Thanks, Paul.
...but I think it's a
pretty decent traybake.
Tough as old boots.
And the top is very sloppy,
so you've got sloppy and tough.
Sounds like a terrible
double act, Sloppy And Tough.
You were right about the rum.
It's very rummy.
Because the amount of apple
that you've put in there,
it brings flavour. Blending
that with the raisin, the rum,
I think you have a beautiful,
traditional traybake.
Not very sophisticated
but a real pleasure to eat.
I think they look very elegant.
You have kept it simple...
Yes... but it is down to that sponge.
I think the marzipan's a bit too
thick for that amount of sponge.
The sponge is very dry. That's
a shame, cos they look great.
Thank you very much for your
feedback. That's great. Thank you.
They look really elegant.
They look all the same size.
Very neat.
Oh, lovely colour. I
love that pale green.
That comes from the pandan
leaf, doesn't it? Yeah.
I love the chiffon. That is lovely.
Textures are perfect.
The look of it's perfect.
But I just don't like the pandan.
No, I accept that. Some people don't.
For me, it's not the right flavour
to go in a traybake, but I admire
the fact that you did it,
because that chiffon's perfect.
I hope, really hope they taste OK.
So do I, cos they look hideous.
I know! I know. I'm sorry.
It's divine. Is it? There you go.
Honestly, I don't care the
way it looks. Really? Yeah.
I have to have another
bite. The almonds in there.
The turron as well. The
whole thing together.
The orange. It's delicious.
Absolutely lovely. Oh, thank you.
Can't believe I'm
crying over a traybake.
Well, I have to say they
look very elegant. Thank you.
I'm not quite sure I'd like a whole
piece of rosemary leaf in my mouth.
Right. But you've got chopped
rosemary inside, haven't you?
Yes. Yes.
I'll tell you what, it's delicious
when you do get a bit of rosemary.
The Italian meringue, it tastes
fine, it just needed more whipping.
Chocolate goes well with it as well.
Sponge is good, but it's down
to those little elegant touches
and I think you lost it slightly
with the Italian meringue.
Thank you.
It looks like a forest floor.
OK. It's a mess. It's broken apart
as you've tried to portion this,
cos some are thin, some are thick.
I think, as a chocolate cake
goes, it's fantastic. Yeah.
I mean, very, very good.
The biggest issue is that
you don't get any cherry.
Right, OK. Maybe more kirsch in
there would have helped as well.
Oh, I'm not sure about the
kirsch but I could eat that
with a great deal of pleasure,
though. Oh, good.
Well, the decoration
is absolutely excellent.
Everything is very
neat. You pipe very well.
It's not too thick. Impressive.
Thank you. I think they
look amazing. Good interior.
Nice and boozy.
Come on. Say something nice.
Like your T-shirt.
Just doing my best here.
That'll do. Oh, wow.
Thank you very much.
What I liked about it,
it looks incredible.
But, when you get inside,
and you do hit that cherry
and the kirsch sits there,
and then the topping,
it's just a really nice cake. I
could sit and eat the whole lot.
He's blushing. He's
actually blushing. I am.
I thought he was joking.
I was waiting for him
to go... "Just kidding!"
And I said I wouldn't
cry, and I did cry.
They were tears of happiness, though.
I was always expecting Paul to
have a gripe but "forest floor"?
He is savage.
The bakers were able to
practise their traybakes
but, with ingredients
shrouded in gingham,
the cake they'll take on
next is a total mystery.
Right, bakers, time for
your Technical Challenge,
which today has been
set for you by Prue.
Any words of advice?
Go like the clappers.
You don't have much time.
Wow. That's made
everybody feel good, right?
Off you two go, and carry
on with your extreme ironing,
whatever you're doing.
For your Technical Challenge today,
Prue would like you to make
an impression of a cake.
Quite literally.
It's her version of the
Impressionist painter
Claude Monet's favourite
birthday treat, Le Gateau Vert.
You need to make a light,
delicate pistachio, genoise sponge.
Green...
Sandwiched with a pistachio
creme au beurre. More green.
And covered in a fondant
coloured green with? Spinach?
Yes. That's a complete fluke.
You have two and a quarter hours.
On your marks... Get set... Bake!
Oh, there's actually spinach.
I thought he was joking.
For the Technical Challenge, the
bakers have identical ingredients...
This is absolutely ridiculous.
...and Prue's pared-down recipe.
In shock.
I don't even know what I'm making.
Prue. Gateau Vert. Claude Monet cake.
What on earth are you thinking?
One of the reasons I really love
this cake is because not only
was it one of Claude Monet's
favourite cakes but he had it
every year on his birthday.
So, how does it get that
beautiful green colour?
It's some spinach puree.
The thicker the puree, the more
green you can get into the fondant.
Those layers look amazing.
The most usual problem with a
genoise is not getting the volume.
It has to be at least an inch
and a bit, so that you can cut it
into three and it'll be light
and delicious. That is beautiful.
This is about the basics being
done well and I think at this
early stage, it's a fantastic challenge.
The person who keeps their
head will do the best because
there's a real danger of panicking
when you see how much you've got to do.
If Prue Leith tells you've got
to hurry, I guess that means
you've got to hurry. "Make
the genoise sponge". OK.
It's actually my favourite
sponge to make. Fingers crossed.
"Place the sugar and
eggs in a large bowl".
You have to whisk it for quite a
high speed, for quite a long time.
All of the lift comes just
from whisking the eggs.
So, that's going to be the tricky bit.
I'm just going to time it,
how long I'm going to whisk it.
I think I'll say about eight minutes.
Fold in pistachios and flour
mixture, butter and lemon zest.
Don't want to knock out any of the air.
What I take now is a little
bit of the genoise and mix it in
with the butter cos then
I find it easier to fold it
into the rest of it. I'm just
a bit concerned about this.
Oh, I know what I've done wrong.
It seems I should have done
something with this and I
didn't and I don't know whether
I should have separated the eggs.
This is not going to go well.
But Karen isn't the
only baker struggling.
I should have done the
whites separately, I think.
Softly. Gently.
It's a question of whether I
just abandon ship or go back.
I'm going to go with it.
I'm trying again.
So, start from the beginning.
It just says "bake".
For... I don't know.
It just says, "bake".
I'm baking for ten minutes
initially, then I'll check on it.
I think it'll be about 15.
Just going for unlucky 13.
I'm sure it'll need at least 20 minutes.
Let's come back in 20.
18 minutes.
Right, bakers, that's half an hour gone.
So, that'll be like a biscuit.
Sandi, that was magnificent.
Thanks, Noel. I mean, I'm
not actually meant to be here.
I just love watching you work.
I know. Thank you so much. OK.
So, now I'm going to make the marzipan.
"Finely grind the pistachios".
Add the icing sugar and combine.
No-one got time to be making marzipan.
You just go and buy it.
I've made marzipan before.
"Add the egg whites
and pistachio essence.
"Knead until smooth, wrap in
clingfilm and leave to rest".
I actually quite liked
Monet, as well, before this.
Do you like Monet, though?
I'm not sure who he is.
I know Monet but I've
never seen this cake.
He did the water lilies. Yeah.
Right.
Do you like van Gogh?
You know van Gogh. Yeah.
Done his ear in, didn't
he, you know? One ear.
My cake does not look right at all.
Oh, it's pretty poor.
I don't want to be scolded
for baking, after this morning
saying I had tough-as-old-boots
sponge, I don't want to do it again.
Oh, my God, his looks so good.
I think I would go with that.
It's come out how I
expected it to come out.
Looking like a cake. You have
totally nailed how Bake Off works.
It hasn't risen.
But anyway...
Oh, mate, this is a disaster.
It's sunk.
Nope.
I don't know whether to start again.
I'm making the cake again.
Like, I've got a flat one
and I can always use that
in an emergency but I need another one.
Started my sponge again.
Oh, God.
"Make la creme au beurre".
Creme au beurre, is, well,
buttercream, basically.
"Add the spinach and cook until wilted".
The colours in a Gateau Vert...
...are all natural. Oh, man.
Oh, look at that. Look at that.
That is green, isn't it?
It's quite weird cos we're
making cake but it smells like...
And it smells like... weird...
...smells like health,
doesn't it? ...boiled cabbage.
Unless the bakers ensure they squeeze
every drop of water from
their pureed spinach...
Let's see how much it is at the moment.
...their creme au beurre
and fondant topping...
...won't have the vivid green
appearance that Monet loved.
OK, yeah, that's the weirdest
thing I've ever done for a cake.
That's a full sack.
Spinach-flavoured creme au beurre.
Conscience is saying
- that's not good.
I hope this one works, cos I
definitely won't have a chance
to do this one again.
This time, I've beaten
my egg whites first.
As Dan and Terry begin baking
a second genoise sponge...
See how we get on with that.
...the rest of the bakers need to
cut theirs into three equal layers.
How anybody's going to slice that
into three is anybody's guess.
When I'm doing this,
I can see where I'm at.
My knife skills are pretty questionable.
OK, we've got one layer.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
That is bad. Very bad.
Second time round, I would
have preferred a bigger rise
on the sponge but
- hey.
Starting again.
Everyone must be looking at me
- "Has he lost the plot?"
Oh, there's so much to do.
Bakers, you have half an hour remaining!
That was the best time call
of the year. Oh, thanks.
Actually sorry, second best.
Going to have to take that back.
Wow. I had an acceptance
speech and everything, ready.
That's the most gracious
defeat of the year.
Oh, thanks so much. Sorry, second.
Second place.
I would have liked to have
spent a bit more time prepping it
and folding it all together
but, just, time's not on my side.
"Sandwich together with
the creme au beurre".
So, you're looking
for that silky texture.
That is absolute liquid.
That's very thin towards the end.
Cover the top and the sides
of the sponge with marzipan.
I made marzipan.
Oh, come on. Please
just do it and be cooked.
Keen to get this excess off
cos it's weighing it down.
Quite pleased with
the marzipan, actually.
It's looking all right.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
Right, this is coming out.
I don't think it's any
better than the other one.
Right, what's next?
"Coat the cake with the icing".
It looks pretty green, isn't it?
I'm just choosing the best bits
from, like, the sponges I've made.
We'll cheat a bit.
Oh, God. Such a mess.
Starting to come together a bit now.
Finally.
Says, "Elegantly decorate
with chopped pistachios
"and edible flowers".
Can't believe I've managed
to do this, to be honest.
Bakers, your time is up.
I'm walking away.
It's a little ring of beauty, isn't it?
It looks like something.
Please place your Gateau Vert
behind your photograph on the table.
Paul and Prue are expecting
Gateau Vert with three even layers
of pistachio genoise
sponge, pistachio marzipan,
and spinach-coloured
fondant and creme au beurre.
And they won't know whose is whose.
Right, shall we start with
this one? Lovely colour.
It's got a nice colour, hasn't it?
That looks like the proper layers.
That's a nice cake. Delicious,
isn't it? The creme au beurre
and the genoise are fantastic.
The pistachio comes through.
Now, the colour's all wrong on this.
The layers aren't too bad.
Nice flavour. Moving on.
Now, it's lost all the
height, hasn't it? Yeah.
Looks quite wet as well.
It's a bit puddingy, to be honest.
OK, moving on. Nice colour.
It is.
That is very nice. It does taste good.
It's quite a rounded cake.
How have they achieved that?
The layers aren't too bad.
Flavour's OK. The filling's
good and the sponge is all right.
Now, this one looks quite nice
when you initially look at it.
The layers are equal.
The flavour's all right...
You seem to have lost a
couple of the layers here.
The creme au beurre, seem
to have lost some of it.
It's quite stodgy, isn't it?
I think it's a bit overcooked.
OK. I worry about this one.
First of all, it's very thin.
They've knocked all the air out
the genoise and the colour's wrong.
Where are the layers?
Very rubbery,
undercooked cake.
That's sad.
I quite like the look of this.
I do, too. It's very pretty.
The cake looks very good.
Tastes of pistachio.
Really beautiful sponge.
I quite like this one as well.
It's got a bit of height to it.
That's a lot of icing on there.
The cake is lovely.
Right, moving on to the last one.
This looks bone-dry on the side,
with a flooding of fondant
on the top. It is. And it's...
It's a bit of a mess.
...over-decorated. Yeah, it is.
The sponge is quite light.
Though not very high.
Prue and Paul will now rank
the cakes from worst to best.
In 11th place, we have this one.
Karen.
You know what's the matter
with it, it wasn't cooked.
In tenth is this one.
Quite stodgy inside, actually.
In ninth place, it's Antony.
Terry is eighth.
Seventh is Luke.
Manon is sixth.
Briony fifth.
And Kim-Joy is fourth.
In third place we have this one.
Dan, it looks lovely
and it tasted great.
So, in second spot...
...is this one. Whose is
this? Pretty good, Rahul.
Nice cake. Well done.
Which means, number one, we have Jon.
Yes. There's nothing to say about
this, it's just a lovely cake.
Thank you. Cheers.
That was amazing. Absolutely
spot on. That is up there.
Birth of the kids, wedding
day, and that. That's there.
Well done, mate. Oh, yeah, definitely.
Yeah, it's OK.
I'm just quite scared
about what's coming next.
It was technical and it
was a challenge. So... yes.
What I always do, when I have
a disappointment, is sort of
crash down like this and, normally,
within a short space of time,
I bounce straight back again.
So, watch this space for tomorrow.
Yeah.
Just the showstopper challenge
remains before we discover who will be
our second Star Baker and who'll
be leaving the Bake Off tent.
Coming into the Showstopper
I think Dan's done well.
First handshake. He is in line
for Star Baker, along with Jon.
Rahul has been
consistently near the top.
Some people need to fight
to stay in the Bake Off
and I would include Manon
in there. This is shocking.
Terry has to be in
there as well, and Karen.
Her gateau vert was a complete disaster.
And likewise, Luke struggled
in the Signature and
didn't do particularly well
either in the Technical.
And I would include Ruby in that.
You said her traybake looked
like a forest floor. It did.
The Showstopper today
involves chocolate.
And it's going to be
extremely hot today.
It's going to be a very
challenging last bake for somebody.
Too hot for a Goth. I'll probably melt.
Hello, bakers, time for
your Showstopper Challenge.
Paul and Prue would love you
to make a chocolate collar cake.
The cake can be any
flavour that you like
but it must be at least two tiers,
encased in chocolate that wraps
all the way around the cake,
hence the name chocolate collar.
The design must be eye-catching and,
of course, the cake must be delish.
You have four hours.
On your marks... get set...
...bake.
Good Lord, I am roasting.
It's much hotter than
chocolate likes to be.
It's one thing to make a cake
but unless you're a chocolatier,
you are not likely to
make a chocolate collar.
Now, the chocolate collar itself
is all about the tempering of
the chocolate, setting it on
acetate and then placing it around
the cake of their choice. You
have to be part architect on this.
Nobody in their right mind
would be dealing with chocolate
on a day like today,
but this is Bake Off and
they're going to have to.
Hello, Jon, you all right?
How are you all, all right?
Well, that looks like pineapple cake.
I'm doing a pina colada cake
cos I like pina colada and
getting caught in the rain.
Jon's pineapple sponge with
coconut buttercream will be wrapped
in a collar, which should bring
his tropical Showstopper together.
My collar is a Hawaiian
shirt going round the outside.
I can't think how you
thought of it, Jon!
Well, where would that come from?
Out of the top of my head or
out of my wardrobe. Either one.
Antony has also raided the
wardrobe for inspiration.
The collar is a sari, which
is worn by most Indian women.
Let's hope I get it down to the tee.
His sari collar will wrap
pistachio and rose water sponge
with saffron buttercream.
The flavours are my
mum's favourite flavours,
so it is a dedication to her.
My mum doesn't like chocolate,
so my sponge is orange
and the cream is chocolate.
Ruby's future in the Bake Off rests on
her mum's favourite
orange liqueur sponge...
Just a splash.
...sandwiched with a chocolate
mascarpone and hazelnut cream,
all wrapped in a collar straight
from the walls of an art gallery.
My collar is inspired
by Jackson Pollock.
Some might just say it's a mess.
Some might say that's very strategic
of me, to have a messy collar.
The judges have demanded the
bakers wrap collars around at least
two tiers of delicious sponge.
It's going to be chocolate
cake, salted caramel cake,
chocolate cake, and there'll
be three tiers of that.
And while some are
going above and beyond,
hoping to avoid an early exit...
...Terry is aiming even higher.
My chocolate collar cake is
going to be the Eiffel Tower.
Two tiers of sponge and then
a lace chocolate topping.
That's quite brave. Yeah.
Have you practised in heat?
I've practised in heat.
I've had my central heating
whacked up to 80 degrees,
working in the kitchen with the oven on.
I hate to see my bill
when it comes through!
Terry's tower will rest on white
chocolate sponge filled with
champagne buttercream and
topped with strawberries.
It's a very summery
sort of flavoured sponge,
and strawberries, champagne, Paris
- you can't go wrong.
All right, Tez.
Oh, perfect Paris, Marie Antoinette.
Exactly. All right? Yeah.
Made a big sacrifice.
You better win.
This is what I do for
you kids, all right?
So make it count in the baking.
That is quite a costume.
I'm going in the oven.
The bakers now face an epic test
of their ability to multitask.
Bake, angels, bake.
With several different-sized sponges...
So, I'm going to put this little
one here so I can keep an eye.
...they'll have to keep track
of multiple baking times...
Six inches will take about 45 minutes.
Eight inches will
take about an hour.
...whilst at the same time prepare
their show-stopping fillings
and decorations.
I'm trying to do a
chocolate sail, if possible.
So that's why I'm making
two instead of one.
If one fails, then at least I have
something to put it on the top.
Rahul's sail will join
chocolate shards and an ornate
Bengali-inspired collar,
wrapping triple-layered chocolate
and orange sponges with a
white chocolate Swiss meringue.
You're doing creme au beurre,
Swiss meringue
buttercream, your collars...
I'm doing a lot... two
different types of sponges.
I'm literally running around
like a headless chicken now.
So I'm just going to do it a
little bit early and then put it
in the fridge for a bit
just to set it a bit.
But I quite like Swiss
meringue buttercream because
it's quite good to do the coating,
and creme au beurre is quite,
like, similar, so it's very
good to stack things up together.
So that's why I'm
doing two buttercreams.
But if I run out of time I
might have no creme au beurre,
just do everything with
Swiss meringue buttercream.
Very succinctly put.
Thank you very much indeed.
Sorry. Look forward to it. Cheers.
Kim-Joy's Showstopper...
Brr.
...is a little more focused.
They're just, like,
little cat silhouettes,
cos I thought it'd
look kind of fun, like,
with them playing all around it.
Her cats will chase a ribbon
around a white chocolate collar that
surrounds genoise sponge filled
with yuzu curd and topped with
even more cats made with fondant.
I think I get a lot of
influences from Japan.
Also kind of makes sense because,
like, cats wear collars, don't they?
So let's hope it's not a cat-astrophe.
After a disappointing first day,
a catastrophic Showstopper
isn't an option for Manon.
So when I was an au pair, I
used to look after a little girl
that I used to love
dressing up as a princess,
so this cake is for her.
She's aiming for a fairy-tale
ending to Cake Week with a fondant
princess and prince for an
almond castle cake wrapped in
a crown of white chocolate
and dark chocolate ramparts.
Sandi's had an accident.
Sandi, get up! It's OK.
That's fantastic.
Is that me and Sandi?
Yeah, well, that's you fast
asleep and that's Sandi,
she's off because you're late.
I think... I don't
think you can say that.
You've been looking at the wrong script.
90 minutes remaining.
I think it needs a few more minutes.
I don't want to bother
them for too long.
It doesn't look that bad. It
actually... I think it's cooked.
Woof.
They've risen a lot better
than the one at home.
They'll need about
another ten minutes or so.
Just going to get these bad
boys out and onto a cooling rack.
Oh, no.
Yeah, that's just raw.
Briony needs to bake three
tiers of chocolate fudge
and salted caramel
cake and fill them with
salted caramel vodka buttercream,
and she plans to wrap them
in a dark chocolate collar
with peanut butter brushstrokes.
I can't serve them raw cake.
That's just not happening.
I'll just have to remake it.
Where's my recipe gone?
Right, take a breath.
Take a breath.
It's looking OK. That one is,
but the other one is
looking very dubious.
Before they can wrap a
collar around their cakes...
They feel nice and bouncy.
...the bakers will need to cover the
rough edges of their cooled sponges.
Oh, I'm just trying to
make the creme au beurre.
I have a lot going on, as usual.
All right, we're now tipping
on some really good saffron.
Smells delicious.
But while most bakers are making
a flavoured buttercream for
their crumb coat, Luke has
chosen a more luxurious approach.
Just whipping the double
cream together now.
I'm doing the last bit by
hand cos it can all of a sudden
just over-whip.
He's making a whipped double cream
and white chocolate crumb coat
for a triple-tiered raspberry
and white chocolate cake
which he'll wrap in an Art Deco collar.
I've now folded in the white chocolate.
It needs to cool a bit,
cos in this temperature
it's just going to not get on well.
Bakers, you have one
hour. Just one hour.
They're still warm. In an ideal
world, you would never do this.
He is a biggie.
Going to start with the smallest
tier and then work my way up,
cos obviously the other
ones are still in the oven.
I'm just concerned that
the buttercream is melting
as it goes on the cake.
It's quite runny.!
My buttercream is just wilting.
Trying to get this neater.
Oh, it's just melting like crazy.
This is awful.
Time is running away fast.
But avoiding molten crumb
coats is just the first battle
in the bakers' war against the heat.
Absolute nightmare.
Oh, Lordy, Lordy, it's hot.
Tempering the chocolate is going to
be the most difficult bit in terms
of the conditions that we're in.
Yeah, so you basically
want to heat it up
and then almost cool it back
down. There's more to it than that,
I'm not saying I know everything
about chocolate tempering.
Bring it up to 38 degrees and then...
No, bring it up to 43 degrees
and then bring it down...
...to 40... 30, I think.
Basically, chocolate has
different types of crystals in it.
So what you do is when you
heat the chocolate, they kind of
break down all the crystals,
and then you cool it quickly
so that some crystals
start forming again.
It sounds a bit funny, doesn't it?
Basically, when you get your
chocolates in the chocolate shop
and they've got a lovely gloss on
them, that's tempered chocolate.
Karen's tempering dark
chocolate to wrap two tiers of
rich chocolate cake filled with
strawberry jam and soaked in
a home-made strawberry liqueur.
But staying in the
competition may depend on her
successfully decorating her
collar with hand-piped lyrics
from a fitting folk song.
♪ As I was going to Strawberry Fair
♪ Singing, singing buttercups and daises
♪ I met a maiden selling
her wares Fol-de-dee. ♪
It's basically about
a prostitute, right?
No, it's about a young lady
that meets a young suitor
and she tempts him with
her wares... Her wares?
...on her way to Strawberry Fair.
Dan's collar decoration will
be a little less freehand.
I've done it twice in practice.
I don't do things timed.
I can't get four hours of
undisturbed time in my house,
so I don't actually do
it against the clock.
Dan still needs to cover his
red-coloured white chocolate stripes
in dark chocolate for a
collar to surround chocolate
and raspberry cakes with raspberry
Italian meringue buttercream.
Hopefully there'll be enough
of a pattern in that one,
cos I can't wait any longer.
How long have we got left?
Bakers, you have half an hour.
30 minutes left.
I'm just going to have
to chill this fast.
Wow. I'm happy with this one.
It's way too hot to be cutting it
but don't have time to mess around.
This is the worst day
ever for doing chocolate.
♪ I like pina colada. ♪
My hand's wobbling really badly.
So I'm going to put the
white chocolate in between,
but obviously need to be quite
careful with the temperatures.
There's something about a sari
that's just extremely beautiful.
India's all about the
colour and the drama.
Yay!
So I don't want too many wrinkles
or anything that's going to distort.
Jackson Pollock would just probably
whack it on but in the same breath,
he's not being judged.
Bakers, you have ten minutes.
Is that right?
At home, five minutes,
the chocolate is set.
Here...
Oh, no, it's melting.
I have just got to
get it round the cake.
Just going to put this as well...
You need to just gauge it,
because if you leave it too long
it's not flexible.
You've only got a few minutes,
really, in which to get it on.
Oh, it's way too stiff now.
I wussed out. Solidly wussed out there.
Making sure that they are OK.
I just need to commit and just do it.
Allez.
Just commit.
Just going to go with it.
This just acts as setting spray.
Just breathe.
It just won't go on. It's just wet.
It shouldn't be like this at all.
Now it's going to go in the fridge.
♪ Say a little prayer for me! ♪
It's not gone to plan.
I've really messed up.
How many minutes do we have left?
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
If you were going to
panic, now's the time.
♪ Under pressure! ♪
I'm not happy with that.
It's going to cool it.
Oh, it's just all completely melted.
It hasn't set because it was too hot.
It's not set. My hands are so warm
as well, I can't even touch it.
The bottom collar I just
didn't have time to remake.
Oh, it's soft. It's just absolutely...
I'm just going to leave
it on. It just didn't set.
Well...
That is just unbelievably bad.
Bakers, your time is up.
Gone.
Please step away from your
chocolate collar cakes.
I mean, it would be really
nice if the bottom one
had a chocolate collar on it.
Paul and Prue will be saying,
"I thought this was Art Deco."
More like art nightmare.
Are you all right?
You OK? What happened?
I just... I can't take the acetate up.
It's not setting.
Dan, would you like to bring
your Showstopper up, please?
I'm really impressed
because, with this heat, to get a
collar round it at all is an event.
I think you've done an amazing
job and the stripes are beautiful.
Well, that's beautiful.
It's rich and moist.
It's delicious.
The Swiss meringue with the
raspberries is bringing a tartness.
Married with the chocolate and the
collar, that's mighty impressive.
Well done, Dan. Thank you.
I'm really impressed with
the cats. They make you smile.
Better taste as good as it looks.
The sponge is quite firm.
It is slightly too dry.
It looks fantastic.
I do like the colours.
Wow. Wow. The colours are just amazing.
I'm not getting pistachio.
There is no pistachio to
blend with the saffron.
It's just saffron in my mouth,
so it tastes almost savoury.
I think it looks amazing.
I love the piping.
The sheen you've got on
the chocolate is very good.
The collar's very neat.
That is really lovely chocolate cake.
It melts in the mouth, which
is perfect. Fair play to you.
That's a great job. Well,
that's great to hear.
Thank you so much. I can't fault it.
It's simple and highly effective.
You've got a great sheen
on that chocolate. I
think it looks amazing.
It is tender. The pineapple
has made it very moist.
I think the sponge is
fantastically baked, and the coconut
really works with it as well.
And I really love
your design. Very good.
Well done. Thank you very much. Cheers.
Luke, would you like to bring
up your Showstopper, please?
Not really!
Sorry about that.
Cream in this sort of heat... Yeah.
...white chocolate in this sort of
heat. Let's see what it tastes like.
It might taste wonderful.
The flavour is delicious
but the cake is tough.
especially with the white
chocolate. Your sponge isn't good.
Is it not good?
It's a nice-looking sponge.
What's going on? Why
wasn't this taken off?
Basically, my chocolate didn't set.
Well, it's set now.
And, now it's off, this
chocolate is beautifully tempered
and absolutely shining.
OK.
That's a very nice sponge. I
think it's a very, very nice cake.
Very smart. Thank you.
It's a shame you didn't
take the acetate off!
Well, I have to say,
I think the way you've done
the ironwork is brilliant.
It may only be half the Eiffel
Tower but everybody knows what it is.
Yes. OK.
What I'm mostly getting is the
sweetness of the buttercream,
and the cake is a bit boring.
Bad luck, Terry. No problem.
Thank you, Terry. You're welcome.
We only asked you for two tiers...
Yes. I know. I know... so you did
get the collar around two. Yes.
We'll have a look at your sponge now.
Oh, look at that.
That is very beautiful.
Thank you.
Your sponge is overbaked.
You can see by the colour on
the outside how dark that is,
and the others are like rubber.
I agree with you that the
textures of the cake are not right
but I think the flavours
are lovely. OK. Thank you.
Wow. It's a wonderful construction.
I'm really impressed that you
managed to keep it together
and it hasn't all fallen down.
Based on the weather today and the heat,
I think you've done an unbelievable job.
Not just to do two collars
but to do this little pipework
across the top as well and then
do the shards on top of that.
I'm impressed, Rahul. Thank you.
You can hear that crack. It's beautiful.
Very bold, strong colours.
Fantastic.
Rahul, can you come
here a minute, please?
I've never given a handshake
for a Showstopper before.
Thank you.
That is a fantastic cake.
Well done, Rahul. Well done, Rahul.
It really is very elegant
and very restrained.
Thank you. It's classy.
I can just tell by the way you're
cutting it that the sponge is
beautifully cooked.
I can sit here eating
this for an hour or so.
It's just delicious.
Thank you. Come here, Ruby.
Yes! Yes! Yes!
That cake, that sponge,
the flavour in there...
The hazelnut and the chocolate...
Every element comes through perfectly.
The collar is so elegant.
The brittle on the
top... That's a fine cake.
Oh, thank you. Oh, I'm made up.
When Prue said that she could sit there
and eat my cake all day long...
...buzzing.
I'm really happy with Paul's handshake.
Would never take that back now.
Like, I'm pleased that
one's in the bag but...
...I wanted to impress Prue.
Good job. Yay. Amazing.
When Paul invited me to the table,
I just first thought that maybe
I have left something stupid
inside the cake, you know, like,
I was poking it with a cocktail stick.
Maybe I left a cocktail stick
inside, so he wanted to show me.
Yeah, that was very surreal.
There weren't any surprises. No.
I'm surprised they even wanted
to judge it, to be honest.
You know it's only a cake.
The logical side of you
knows it's only a cake and,
at the end of the day, it's
not the end of the world.
It weren't as bad as mine, at least.
Look at it that way.
At least you had a collar on it!
Prue and Paul must now decide
who will be our second Star Baker
and who will have to
leave the Bake Off tent.
It was an extraordinary day,
because we went in very clear about
the people who were in trouble,
and all that has changed.
I was so pleased with Ruby and Karen,
because they looked in such trouble.
And Manon. I think those
three people saved themselves.
I think we've got Luke and
Terry down at the bottom.
Yeah, and they didn't
even look good, did they?
Briony's Showstopper
wasn't particularly good.
She let herself down.
She's better than that.
The cake was stodgy.
I think when you're
looking at Star Baker,
Jon did a great job
with his pineapple cake,
I think Rahul's done a fantastic
job, and I also feel like
Dan has been probably the
most consistent throughout all.
Absolutely steady.
Quite amazing that two
handshakes happened.
I've never given a handshake
on a Showstopper before,
but to give two... I'm
disappointed with myself!
But it... The only... The only reason...
We're disappointed with
you, too. I know. Yeah.
Bakers, what a tremendous,
cake-fuelled weekend we have had,
and I have the pleasure of
announcing the Star Baker.
The person who is this week's
Star Baker made a giant of
a tray bake, has been
technically consistent,
and persuaded Paul
to give his first-ever handshake
in a Showstopper.
Rahul!
Unfortunately, that means I
get to deliver the bad news.
The person who's leaving
us this week is...
...Luke.
I know, I know. It
wasn't my weekend, hey?
I'm just going to, like,
really miss everybody here.
Oh, mate, mate! I've lost my mate!
I just can't believe I've even made
it onto the show in the first place.
Just little old me, who just,
like, bakes in his kitchen,
started with his nan, taught himself.
But, hey, I was still in the Bake
Off, I still went in the tent,
I still had Paul and
Prue try food I've baked,
which is, like,
literally, a dream of mine.
Next week, next week? I know,
next week, I will. Thank you.
I am so relieved to still be here.
I'm not going to cry!
I'm not going to cry.
Nope.
No, I'm not!
Still here, Terry.
Still here. Still in shock, I think.
It's a bit surreal, actually,
how much you do want it.
I will return home tomorrow and
practise, practise, practise!
Well done, Rahul. You can cheer up now.
Yeah, I will try, yeah. Thank you.
All right? Yeah, yeah. I just...
Yeah, my emotions just
go a little bit crazy.
It feels so surreal.
Hollywood handshake
and the Star Baker...
Well done!
I just hope I didn't peak too early.
Next time...
And we're off... it's Bread Week...
Come on, bread. Don't let me down.
...and Paul's not taking any prisoners...
Makes me nervous.
...with a fruity classic
Signature Bake...
Do you want to see my buns?
...a heated Technical Challenge
that's a British takeaway favourite...
I genuinely have no idea.
...and show-stopping sweet breads
that are the largest
ever baked in the tent.
It is a big waiting game, but
it's worth it, you see? Worth it.